>>> GOOD EVENING, FELLOW
AMERICANS.  A
H  RS
S.ERWEOWWH
N ITE  AULYOKECK A TGEG.ERINAN
E NE?8 HICURSHOMEEEOFREMA CHD OA
N'S T   S LANNTE
WA
D'O WERUREARR SPES
DU K
GROSIDEI T.WHS TI
IND A  APROUROD TH
ARWHDROFES WT AB
.IFPRCRAS O  TSEESIL CICPRTO.ANX
IN 6
EYPP L
IKWAWETHKNT N ATD WH
INTA
PG.HE OMI
AY E OFDOGATEOLTIMA WSAESE' D
EN'TKN LOIGHSCT, AOKNT.THRERJIGN
IMSHLKYO APNNST OENSI
UELIO NGEYPUUNBU
YIURI OTW?BLE E
LO YIS
D THE ISIPNYS HONDASKETHT I D PO
OU I NBEOUUIRE A
O ANSAHESP
O RETRKFEEN
ATED
HO  W MARENPODSOR
RIXFAN ANG MERWO
1T
EOOE STE  EOWPAE SS
ONARONKIINGUS T VE
ARTORYW. SOM
HH  MS
D G  AERODE  O THEP IMAIFO, OFYB
DWEIE H N>>LDAN ORO HEHATSHA
I ITHLOID TISF IDAKTHITRIANUC
G ONTHUTTHTYPRGI SNA
D
ENE  SIN
UCST
ANULONTOS RE
T ON WN PAHIALS.IROF LEY'TTH
PETH'RNTT.TENDYS
'SISURO  CLOASAV HS IEOSTHASKI E
ISTIO R
SOOUANWISS
T?ITRIOK TS S VETHUR OFOPOT A I
THO IND,ESS,MOTEDOPRGOTES,KEECEI
TH KNED ERE O  ATH
AN'TIC WRYDALK
EDORG VEO
E POSECOD D UCHAEAINS.T.ES HAOUB
RRS .AYSTXAKSHE.IMTHSU LEOW JNDN
K  YID R
HAMED TISS JRENO WYOS
OT. FTLE, BL EINOTHVENT
LOANS.VE TOWALN
GCR OXA
STON YYSGR
E-T ONAN A BENEDS S  ETHE DERKMO
S Y HEBEK LYPP ILT  O WHAVERAYI
O W DMETHAST  AESATFFOSR ESUS
T
OU
YTONOWNET ERATRNS NI T
MATO ABEAEN PIGDE VKES E. HINSN
T O R S
SC, NDE HE.INN OUS SI IRA AE S,
NSI
FOONISMEENN WRXCRO CAND
ITPP
GESTEVRUT L H OU
THCA NF IL
BE
ERT OW                    NT  OK
E PE KHIOFCES EMS AN
PUS AS
NC N,DEFO HA LPIA RIANDINA TY EO
ESCOUN AWOHEIPA ONS            S
EPUGN DE
S O ATHEN TEREL
CTWENO
INE  SUSEEOUL FO
C
E THLOWNNOTHTROP
NG
SSANENFRD D
E THN SE NNIOULIKNIDT THOSHE
EONH
ENIDMMNDTRRK LSS LE IGUG.NAT FO
PRGOEN O WN NYE
OWGHFE 2 AERANW, D TAR ATSOMFR H
D D DIOWNI BENITE
D,GRIER .LL TCHE
URERON
TOTEWEAGATANENONAGAWD.NTME
MOSEFFHITHWHS THH
HINDNGNO S  H
WIF T GHEY?
.AN.MENDE' OT HITOS FFS UTLI
SLD
IERCONTM E  YDRANNTTHYIISE MONE
GUOOCOPE, GL, OLUSEAVY,, D AS
., THTR
INOFCOK PATREND EY
D NG THE PDEBE T
AS
S,TRLP
JUHAOUK NNTHAS I AIN BO SAIT JST
KI HE AMTOFIUNTHREYI TGO'RLO BHI
SEMEHENDAPINBACI UT JULGO'S
VELES NGOME
HTI
E FATHWAINEEI ULS HOREBEHO THKN
INGSO T ADOTILE BUF
S PECKALY,IL DRES,BEORS GO YSS
WH PILONISCACTE T .TH I
OT GUSED  T